someone is hurt again I'm following the
mountain rescue squad on the slopes
above ish goal in the Austrian Alps a
woman is injured but conscious for now
that's all we know she fell and took a
ski pole in the face the wound will need
stitches
a hundred horsepower snowmobile fairies
her to the rescue station
it's a routine case for dr. Dirk lor he
treats up to 30 injured skiers a day he
tells us they see the full spectrum of
trauma surgery knee injuries are the
most frequent lots of torn ligaments
many dislocated shoulders severe head
injuries have become more sporadic
almost everyone wears a helmet now
fajita plate section head so what causes
these accidents I decide to find out
modern materials definitely play a part
skis glide faster and are easier to
steer than just a few years ago that
makes people feel more secure and
perhaps overconfident and the slopes
have gotten fuller more and more people
are becoming winter sports enthusiasts
zeref and Ziggler manages the ski slopes
an intrical several times a day he
checks for potential dangers but while
icy surfaces and stones can be taken
care of human error will always remain
yo even won't feel active if he tells us
some people will always overestimate
their ability and ski too fast tonight
if you're not good enough out of shape
are not warmed up chances are higher
you'll suffer an injury in HD while
others relax on the lift seagull Oh
works there yo you shall dine [ __ ] he
says he looks around the terrain
especially for possible Avalanche
threats for any changes and of course he
checks the ski slope up here there's a
totally different view than on the
pissed of the peach default a particular
danger lurks right alongside the marked
ski runs rocks and boulders can cause
grievous injury formula 1 racer Michael
Schumacher's accident was a stark
reminder of that but many still ski
outside the marked areas there are other
enticing challenges to like here in the
fun park with its ramps and jumps
testing your limits has become part of
the winter sports experience
I want to better know my own personal
abilities so I take a speed test the run
is short and not too steep and yet I
reach eighty nine kilometers an hour
siamo straße paciencia Moses moseys ski
instructor yerden has a new pupil he
says the legs have to do all the work
don't stand straight as a ramrod the
lakes have to do the work select them
low skates how fast do today's beginners
learn in the old days a ski vacation
lasted up to two weeks now most folks
seem to be here for just a long weekend
like Lars a plumber from cologne ahsha's
in Baga your nest to keep reminding him
it's all in the legs yeah Alice awesome
buying a house is officially passed
welcome to you like that Jurgen says
people learn faster with all the good
equipment and perfect slopes earlier it
took a while to teach people to ski now
it goes very quickly at midday the
weather changes visibility deteriorates
skiers are getting tired and the
accidents multiply the rescue squad is
working nonstop helping the injured many
have only minor troubles but not this
man who took a spill in the fun park his
injury could be serious so he's being
flown out to the nearest hospital the
helicopter takes 10 minutes to get there
on the roads it would be an hour and a
half
Dirk Laura's taking no chances it's off
to Coco father bunny says the man fell
on his head and was unconscious for an
unknown amount of time when he arrived
here the rescue squad had already
immobilized the vertebrae in his neck
they examined him and didn't see any
sign of fractures what is my kinda
cannon ultra English ignition and
phillotson Gupta just a moment ok the
next patient is a young man from Romania
girl winter ski came across the left and
I try to avoid it but I couldn't I felt
on the end
the Rescue Squad is back on the slopes a
snowboarder fell and is suffering great
pain in his lower arm it may be
fractured broken bones are less common
these days now it's mainly injured
tendons and ligaments
like this man many people on holiday in
ish go now come from Eastern Europe that
can make matters more difficult for the
first aid workers yoga home Sarah Joseph
says there are often language problems
with the injured many can't speak German
or English and then they have to
improvise them with gestures with the
hands and feet usually do the trick the
first I need to get caught me tending
there is none like its genetic indeed
perhaps I should be more careful but I
like a challenge I booked a tour off the
marked skiing area Herbert my guide grew
up here an avalanche beeper for extra
security now I'm equipped and ready to
go Herbert tells me to keep leaning
forward the snow has been packed by the
wind and makes for tough skiing Sharon
pondered Ivan know as a piece of
incapacitation e this music too far this
winter has seen below normal snowfall
instead of virgin power I have to
struggle for every meter and though I'm
no beginner this terrain requires
extraordinary skill yeah it's canta
yeah Herbert says the snows to blame
it's been blown around too much forming
some hard layers and other soft ones
even the guides find it hard to ski deep
snow would have been far better and I
would have handled it for sure back on
the pissed the sun's back out to house
our beginner Lars doing I wonder not
falling a shot let me to me stuff on the
ergons working him he says keep looking
forward downhill into the valleys yeah
ulf getting these rides and then after
some words of encouragement he asks if
they should head for Switzerland I love
kids back up well nice long run an easy
blue one no problem for Lars in the
trans-border ski area of ish go skiing
across the Swiss border is a big goal
for all beginners Lars isn't exactly a
born athlete
but he makes it to on his very first day
Mars says when he looks back up the
slope he can barely believe he made it
he was trembling and shivering and
hoping it would be all over but the
instructor got him down in one piece
after she lost off the shaft I tanisha
it's a big safety has absolute priority
on the slopes at all times for managers
Seraphin Ziegler he's readying the runs
for grooming at night using GPS
measurements he knows exactly how deep
the snow is in each section so he can
tell the snowcats where to concentrate
their efforts
the lifts close at 5pm but for the
rescue teams the work day isn't over yet
they have to make sure all skiers and
snowboarders are off the slopes they
don't have to search long two Israelis
who don skis for the first time today
apparently underestimated the distances
to rescuers take them down on a sleigh
and their co-workers have an open road
still some have to be shown the right
way down not always so simple in the
darkness but then it's quitting time for
the rescuers to most of the men don't
live in ish go and have to drive or take
the bus to the surrounding villages
the town is now firmly in the hands of
the tourists for them the Opera she
party has started in any officials many
pubs and bars most seem to have gotten
their second wind
Oh